on the Republican side mr. Trump was
asked about it and said something like
you know things like that happened in
the world and Governor Bush said yeah
stuff happens
know that that's a that's an admission
of defeat and surrender to a problem
that is killing 33,000 Americans
somebody will say well you know if we
only had more guns you're walking to
class you're driving your baby around in
a car seat you're going to church if
somebody has an automatic weapon or even
worse an assault weapon that is a
military instrument of war and you're
somehow supposed to be able to stop that
with your own gun that has never made
any sense ideally what I would love to
see is gun owners responsible gun owners
hunters form a different organization
and take back the Second Amendment from
these extremists
we need to go back and with all of our
hearts working not just in Washington
but from the grassroots up demand that
we have universal background checks we
have to close the loopholes
you know we've got what's called the gun
show loophole and we've got what's now
being called the Charleston loophole the
proposals that I'm making they're not
new there's nothing you know unique
about them other than the fact that I am
so determined we're going to do
everything we possibly can to get this
done